sur le terrain comme en coulisses
emmeline ndongue et l'ajout ambassadrice
du sport
quatre titres de champion de france avec
le tango bourges basket une médaille
d'argent aux jeux olympiques de londres
est désormais un rôle dans
l'organisation des jeux de paris 2024
son but profiter de l'événement pour
promouvoir l'activité physique auprès
des plus jeunes on sait que les enfants
ne bougent pas assez sont beaucoup trop
statique passe aussi beaucoup de temps
devant devant les écrans qu'ils ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est qu'un enfant qui est
acquis en bonne santé ce sera un adulte
qui sera en bonne santé et donc il est
important de prendre les bonnes
habitudes dès le plus jeune âge
et là c'est ce qui c'est ce qu'ils font
c'est ce qui nous montre en s'activant
un petit peu tout les jeux tous les
jours trente minutes csn minimum bougies
plus au quotidien c'est aussi le credo
de tony estanguet
le président du comité d'organisation
des jeux de paris 2024 et venues dans le
cher vanter les mérites du design actif
un concept d'aménagement urbain bientôt
déployée à bourges
c'est de la signalétique au sol c'est
des équipements très léger pour
permettre là aussi bien de faire
quelques assouplissements quelques
exercices de temps en temps pour ceux
qui le souhaitent mais au delà de ça
c'est vrai que nous montrant je ne sais
pas tellement d'inciter les gens à une
pratique intensive
c'est juste de la marche déjà dans un
premier temps en attendant la ville mise
beaucoup sur ces olympiades de quartier
des épreuves sportives qui verront
s'affronter huit secteurs de bourges
début juillet toute la ville de bourges
du 3 au 11 juillet va être mobilisée sur
la thématique de mini jeux olympiques à
la dimension de bourges pour justement
créé c'était cet esprit olympique et
faire que ça soit une grande fête du
sport qui ne soit pas qu'à paris
avis aux amateurs les inscriptions sont
ouvertes jusqu'au 28 mai